so
imagine a company hires a new employee
best in the business who's on a
multi-million dollar contract
now imagine that whenever this employee
went to go meet with their team members
the appointments were ignored or
dismissed and in the meetings that did
happen
she was yelled at or kicked out after a
few minutes
so after a while she just went quietly
back to her desk sat there none of her
skills being put to use
of course being ignored by most people
and of course still getting paid
millions of dollars
this hot shot employee can't seem to
catch a break
is that company's technology
this scenario is not an exaggeration
in my job as a technology advisor i've
seen so many companies make the
well-meaning decisions to put huge
investments into technology
only to have the benefits fail to live
up to the expectation
in fact in one study i read 25
of technology projects are canceled or
deliver things that are never used
that's like billions of dollars just
being wasted each year
so why is this
well from what i've seen the expectation
from the top management is high but not
unreasonable about the benefits from the
technology
they expect people will use them
it will create time savings and people
will become genuinely better at their
jobs
but the reality is that the people on
the front line who are supposed to be
using these softwares and tools
they're skeptical or even afraid
we postpone the online trainings we
don't bother to learn the shortcuts and
we get frustrated at the number of tools
we have to remember how to log into and
use
right
and that frustration that guilt it's
racking up the more that technology is
inserting itself into our daily working
lives
which is a lot
brookings says that 70 of jobs today in
the us require at least mid-level
digital skills
so basically to work these days
you need to be able to work with
technology
but from what i've seen we are not
approaching this with the right mindset
so here's the idea that i've been toying
with
what if we treated technology like a
team member
i've been running my own personal
experiment about this
i've spoken to people from all different
industries about how they can treat
their core technologies like colleagues
i've met with people from restaurant
industry medical professionals teachers
bankers people from many other sectors
and the first step with anybody that i
would meet with was to draw out the
structure of their teams in an
organization chart
now
am a total geek when it comes to
organization charts
org charts are really cool
because if they are drawn well you can
quickly get a sense of what individual
roles are and also how a team works well
together
but if you look at a typical org chart
it only includes the boxes and lines
that represent people
none of the technology team members are
there they're all invisible
so for each of the organizations that i
met with for my experiment i had to draw
a new type of org chart
one that also included the technology
and when i did this people i spoke to
could actually visualize their
technologies as co-workers and they
could ask things like
is this software reporting to the right
person
does this man in machine team work well
together
is that technology actually the team
member that everybody's awkwardly
avoiding
so i will walk you through an example of
a small catering company to bring this
experiment to life
this is the top layer of people who work
at bobbington's catering company there's
a sales director manages all the
customer interactions
and there's an operations director
manages all the internal activities
and here's the people who report to the
sales and operations directors
and finally here's the view where we've
overlaid the software and the hardwares
that's used by the bobbington staff
now using this amazing org chart we can
now explore how the human team members
and the technology team members are
interacting
so the first thing that i'm going to
look for is where there's a human and
machine relationship that's extra
critical
usually it's somebody using a technology
on a day-to-day basis to do his or her
job
at bobbington's finance director with
the accounting platform would be one
next i would check on the status of
their collaboration
they working well together getting along
in this case it turned out to be a
tenuous relationship
so what to do
well
if the accounting platform were actually
a person the finance director would feel
responsible for managing it taking care
of it
well in the same way
my first suggestion was to think about a
team building activity
maybe
getting together on a specialist course
and my second suggestion was to think
about scheduling regular performance
reviews for the accounting platform
where the finance director would
literally give feedback to the company
who sold it
now there will be several of these
really important human and machine teams
in every organization so if you're in
one it's worth taking the time to think
about ways to make those relationships
truly collaborative
next i'll look on the chart for any
human role which might be overloaded by
technology let's say interacting with
four or more types of applications
at bobbington's operations director was
interacting with five technologies
now he told me that he'd always felt
overwhelmed by his job but it wasn't
until our conversation that he thought
it might be because of the technologies
he was overseeing
and we were talking that if the
operations director had actually had a
lot of people reporting to him
probably would have done something about
it because it was stretching him too
thin
like move some of them to report to
somebody else
so in the same way we talked about
moving some of the technologies to
report to someone else like the food
inventory to go to the chef
the last thing that i'll look for is any
technology that seems to be on the org
chart without a real home
sometimes they're floating around
without an owner
sometimes they're reporting to so many
different areas that you can't tell
who's actually using it
now at bobbington's nobody appeared to
be looking after the marketing software
it was like someone had hired it and
then didn't give it a desk any
instructions on what to do
so clearly needed a job description
maybe someone to manage it
but in other companies you might find
that a technology has been sidelined for
a reason
like it's time for it to leave or be
retired
now
retiring applications is something that
all companies do
but maybe by taking the mindset that
those applications are actually
co-workers could help them decide when
and how to retire those applications in
the way that would be least disruptive
to the rest of the team
i did this experiment with 15 different
professionals and each time it sparked
an idea
sometimes a bit more
you remember that hotshot employee i was
telling you about everybody was ignoring
that was a real story told to me by
christopher
a very energetic human resources manager
at a big consumer goods company
technology was a new hr platform
and it had been installed for 14 months
at great expense and but nobody was
using it
so we were talking about how
if this had really been such a hotshot
employee with amazing credentials you'd
go out of your way to get to know it
maybe invite them for coffee you know
get to know their background
so
in the spirit of experimentation
christopher set up one hour appointments
coffee optional
for his team members to have no agenda
but to get to know their hr system
some people they clicked around menu
item by menu item
other people they searched online for
things that they weren't clear about
a couple of them got together gossiped
about new software in town
and a few weeks later christopher called
to tell me that people were using the
system in new ways and he thought it was
going to save them weeks of effort in
the future
and they also reported feeling less
intimidated by the software
i found that pretty amazing that taking
this mindset helped christopher's team
and others that i spoke to this past few
months
actually feel happier about working with
technology
and i later found out this is backed up
by research
studies have shown that people who work
in organizations that encourage them to
talk about and learn about the
technologies in the workplace have
twenty percent lower stress levels than
those in organizations that don't
i also found it really cool that when i
started to do this experiment i started
with what was happening between a person
and an individual technology but then it
ultimately led to ideas about how to
manage tech across entire companies
like when i did this for my own job and
extended it
i thought about how our data analysis
tools should go on the equivalent of a
job rotation program where different
parts of the company could get to know
it
and i also thought about suggesting to
our recruiting team that some of the
technologies we work with every day
should come with us on our big
recruiting events
if you're a university student how cool
would it be to not only get to know the
people you might be working with but
also the technologies
now all of this begs the question
what have we been missing by keeping the
technologies that we work with day to
day invisible
and what beyond those billions of
dollars in value might we be leaving on
the table
the good news is you don't need to be an
org chart geek like me to take this
experiment forward
will take a matter of minutes for most
people to draw out a structure of who
they work with a little bit longer to
add in the technologies to get a view of
the entire team
and then you can have fun asking
questions like which are the
technologies that i'll be taking out for
coffee
now i didn't do this experiment for
kicks or for the coffee
i did it because the critical skill in
the 21st century workplace is going to
be to collaborate with the technologies
that are becoming such a big and costly
part of our daily working lives and from
what i was seeing we are struggling to
cope with that
so might sound counterintuitive
but by embracing the ideas that these
machines are actually valuable
colleagues we as people will perform
better and be happier
so let's all share a bit of humanity
towards the technologies and the
softwares and the algorithms and the
robots who we work with because we will
all be the better for it
thank you
[Music]